moving on
our main story tonight concerns
pandemics you know the thing every
little virus could one day grow into
wait even me yeah maybe even you mystery
virus
wow that's great thanks for helping me
believe in myself john
now if you'll excuse me i'm off to the
mall of america
okay have fun i'm probably going to
regret that
and i know you might be thinking right
now john shut the up
no one wants to hear any more about the
coronavirus and i do get that which is
why
we're not actually going to talk about
the current pandemic tonight
we're going to talk about the next one
instead which i know
sounds even less appealing but look we
are the show we are
if you want to see a british person do
something hot or interesting
go watch bridgeton lot of in
blankets on that show
however much you expect there's
significantly more
but now might also be the most important
time to talk about this because
scientists attempted to warn us about
the next pandemic
long before the current one hit and we
didn't really listen in fact
17 years ago just after the sars
epidemic was contained
a leading scientist was on 60 minutes
sounding a chilling warning
what worries me the most is that we're
going to miss the next emerging disease
that we're going to suddenly find a sars
virus
that moves from one part of the planet
to another wiping out people as it moves
along
something more lethal than sars is what
worries you that's something to be
keeping you awake at night uh yeah it is
because that is a hauntingly spot-on
prediction there
i kind of wanted him to continue uh just
spitballing here what if that guy from
the apprentice becomes president
or some lonely goon at harvard invents a
website that destroys the fabric of
society as we know it
that's something to keep you awake at
night too look i know this current
coronavirus might feel like a once in a
lifetime nightmare but it's actually
part
of a global trend because the total
number of infectious disease outbreaks
has increased significantly since 1980.
we've seen outbreaks like sars in 2003
h1n1 in 2009
a series of ebola outbreaks most notably
in 2014 mers in 2015
zika that same year and of course the
current virus that we're all enjoying
which is the main reason
why i am currently speaking to you
completely alone from what looks like
the pillsbury doughboy's ass
crack and the truth is if we're not very
careful
the next pandemic could well be even
worse there are viruses currently
circulating in wildlife
they essentially kill 60 to 70 percent
of the people they infect
the virus that causes covet 19 might
just be a dress rehearsal for
the big one later this is not by any
stretch of the imagination
uh the worst mother nature has to offer
us well that doesn't sound great
and look i know this isn't the most
important thing there but what is it
with disease experts and predicting
upcoming pandemics while on boats that's
a terrible use of a boat
they're supposed to be chill read the
boat rules one the captain's always
right
two only fish on days that end in y and
three no grim tidings at the voral
apocalypse did you hear that
that's a boat foul dr bummer
indeed and while you would hope that the
last year would have been a wake-up call
to everyone those who study pandemics
are skeptical that we've learned
nearly enough i think the what i've seen
in history of looking at these pathogens
over time is that we usually go
right back to business as usual as soon
as the thing ends as soon as we have a
drug as soon as we have a vaccine
as soon as we can kind of get away these
diseases into
marginalized populations we don't really
do the fundamental social change
that we could do exactly unfortunately
there is every chance that after all
this is over we'll end up treating the
coronavirus like a really bad fart at
thanksgiving
that is waiting patiently for it to
dissipate so we can never speak of it
again
and collectively pretend that it didn't
just kill grandma
so given all of that tonight let's talk
about the next pandemic specifically
where new infectious diseases come from
why they're on the rise
and what we can do to limit them and
let's start with how we got into our
current situation
the kovic 19 pandemic is caused by a
novel coronavirus called sars
cov2 which originated in animals before
jumping to humans and that
is by no means unusual it's estimated
that up to 75
of new or emerging infectious diseases
come from animals they're called
zoonotic diseases or zoonosis not to be
confused with
zunos which for the record is a very
hurtful thing to call a teenager
who's already got enough to deal with
and covid is by no means the only
zoonotic disease out there there are an
estimated 1.7
million currently undiscovered viruses
in mammals and birds of which
between six and eight hundred thousand
could have the ability
to infect humans and lots of animal
species
are hosts for zoonotic disease birds and
pigs can harbor influenza
chimpanzees with a bridge of hiv to
humans and turtles can carry salmonella
which is something that we all remember
from one of the darkest episodes of the
ninja turtles cartoon
that's right one of their turtle powers
seem to be inadvertently killing april
o'neil
now one of the biggest vectors for
transmitting viruses is famously bats
they've been linked to ebola the deadly
nipa virus and kovid19 in fact
here is that eerily pressing expert that
you saw earlier warning of the dangers
of a popular bat based tourist
attraction
back in 2016. the bats here
in this cave are the same bats that
carry sars virus
when they're up there they urinate and
defecate
right on top of the tourists that are
walking through and all you've got to do
is be that one person to
breathe in at the wrong time and
suddenly you've been infected with a
with a virus that is
not only potentially lethal to people it
could cause a future pandemic that's
horrible
and not just the disease parts just the
very concept of this
walk-in bat toilet being a tourist
destination that might be the worst
tourist attraction since
disneyland put johnny depp animatronics
in the pirates of the caribbean right
come on disney there's kids here they're
here to watch some jolly nautical
rapists and thieves
not a weird sad millionaire doing a b
plus keith richards
now there are reasons that bats are such
good hosts for disease they can fly so
they can
cover large distances they've developed
specialized immune systems that don't
overreact to infections which
keeps them from falling ill and they are
insanely plentiful
nearly a quarter of the world's mammal
species are
bats and if you're thinking well that's
great then there's an easy fix here
let's simply kill all bats that's
actually
not a great idea for multiple reasons
not only are they crucial elements of
our ecosystem they're also
way cuter than they're often given
credit for just look at this
fuzzy little goober eating a banana look
at this one
scarfing down a watermelon and just look
at this little guy trying to absolutely
house a single grape look at him go
who's struggling with a grape
you are you're struggling with a grape
you little goth mouse
also it is important to remember that
the fact that we may have caught covered
from bats isn't so much
their fault as it is ours because
outbreaks of bad viruses don't tend to
come from them
seeking us out they usually happen when
a human takes a bat
somewhere it'd never go on its own or
intrudes on its home and that
actually brings us to the first big
thing we're doing
that may well bring about the next
pandemic and that is erasing the buffer
between civilization and wildlife
scientists have repeatedly warned us
about the dangers of deforestation
urbanization mining and generally
supplanting natural habitats which has
been
far more extensive than you might think
many people
imagine there's this untouched
wilderness because they see it on their
tv screens
but the reality is there's really not a
lot of wild left out there
we've already lost nearly 90 of the
wetlands around the world
we've transformed the forests our
grasslands
we've converted 75 of the land that is
not covered by
ice three quarters of the terrestrial
surface has been changed
a lot of it's just to feed one species
it's true
we've changed three quarters of the
earth's land areas
and while some of that was necessary we
have also changed a lot to build
dumb pointless that no one really
wants or needs like
paintball courses or novelty t-shirt
shops or
salt lake city and that vanishing
boundary has brought increased risk
over 30 percent of new and emerging
diseases are linked to deforestation
and land use change take the amazon
studies have documented that clearing
patches of forest appears to create the
ideal habitat
along forest edges for the type of
mosquito that's the most common
transmitter of malaria there
or take west africa the first victim of
2014's ebola outbreak
was a young boy who'd been seen playing
near a tree infested with bats before he
got sick
he lived in a small village where much
of the surrounding forest had been
destroyed by foreign mining and timber
operations
and evidence suggests that that is what
brought the bats into his village
and before you think this is just an
overseas problem
it is worth remembering that one of the
clearest examples of habitat destruction
fueling and emerging disease
happened right here in the united states
where lyme disease
was first identified in connecticut in
the 1980s and was
driven by suburbanization what we found
is that
the probability that a tick is going to
acquire an infection when it feeds on a
white-footed mouse
is about 90 percent as we fragment the
landscape we chop up
continuous force into little bits we
lose species they disappear
one of the last creatures is the
white-footed mouse
so as we reduce diversity we're losing
the species that protect us
and favoring the ones that make us sick
right we fragmented the landscape and
that
drove out predators leaving creatures
like white-footed mice who are the main
culprits when it comes to lyme disease
transmission and you know what that
means
white-footed mice they can go
themselves unlike of course rats
who can and should go each other
but it's not just
us moving closer to animals it's that
more and more we are bringing wild
animals into contact with us
through the wildlife trade now sometimes
that takes the form of exotic pets
whether it's when
paris hilton got a kinkajou named baby
love or
this random british man's extremely
ill-advised roommate
an ordinary street in kent and a
suburban semi
with a normal conservatory but it's
licensed for something
far from normal is a crocodile a
suitable pet to have in a
suburban house like this he's certainly
mellow he's not the same animal he would
be because he's
he's adjusted shall we say to human life
having something that no one else has
got
is is an interesting thing i mean
sure i guess that's true but even
if you insist on owning a wild animal
which you really shouldn't
why a crocodile they're not remotely
cuddly you're basically flooding your
broom closet to make room for a
carnivorous surfboard
the only acceptable human use for any
crocodile or alligator is as the star
of the internet's single greatest music
[Music]
video
that is excellent that song is catchier
than sars
in a good way the point here is exotic
pet ownership has caused real problems
in 2003 47 people across six states
caught monkey pox
which had never infected humans outside
of africa after having contact with
infected prairie dogs purchased as pets
and in 2006 paris hilton had to go to
the hospital after her kinkajou bit
her and it's hard to say which was worse
there a u.s monkey pox outbreak or
baby loves shocking betrayal at two
kinkajou but perhaps the most famous way
wild animals can spread disease to
humans is when they're sold for
consumption
and the phrase you're probably already
thinking of right now is
wet markets like the one in wuhan which
may well have been the breakout site of
covid19 and you should know here
the term wet market is used incredibly
broadly and often incorrectly
many wet markets are essentially just
places where fresh meat seafood and
produce
are sold not unlike a farmer's market
and they can be key sources
of fresh affordable food around the
world especially in developing areas
where there isn't you know
a trader joe's three blocks away however
some of those markets do sell wildlife
like bats and snakes and conditions in
some of those wildlife markets
can be ideal for disease transmission so
here in cages right next to each other
we've got uh adult raccoons
next to capybara which is from south
america
north america cages right next to each
other this is the biggest rodent in the
world
and on top of here i think uh these
marmosets on top of the pepe barra
what we just saw here is it's like a
biological warfare lab
any one animal can transmit a pathogen
to another
somebody buys it handles it takes it
home as a pet or eats it
boom we have another pandemic right
when wild animals from different parts
of the world are held in close proximity
with weakened immune systems due to
stress
pathogens can easily jump from one
species to another and potentially
to humans which should at the very least
make you seriously rethink your island
in animal crossing
you honestly still think it's a good
idea to live in close proximity with a
raccoon not
to available shut that down and
listen
i know it doesn't sound great whenever
someone particularly with this accent
starts tut-tutting about how people in
other countries feed themselves and make
a living and
for what it's worth before we go tell
everyone else what to do
we might want to acknowledge that our
track record on mixing animals isn't
great
either one expert that we spoke to said
a major concern of theirs is state fairs
which does kind of make sense state and
agricultural affairs have been linked to
multiple disease outbreaks with one in
2012 that affected over 300 people
mostly children across 10 states that
probably explains why fairgoers have
been repeatedly warned no
kissing pigs and look it's easy to think
come on
i'd never kiss a pig but are you really
sure about that what about this one
now you're not so sure are you what
about this one right here
now you're even more confused how about
this pig exactly
i thought so well i've got great news
this hot little pork chop's been
watching you across the bar
all night it's down for some stuff
and america is actually ground zero for
another dangerous practice here
factory farming it's something that
started here but has since
skyrocketed around the world to the
point that factory farms now supply more
than 90 percent of meat globally
and 99 of meats domestically
in factory farms livestock are bred and
confined in ways
that can enable viruses to spread among
them much more easily
if you have several thousand hogs packed
in together and they're all genetically
largely the same then it selects for the
most virulent pathogens that are
possible
and so in the course of industrializing
livestock
production we are also industrializing
the pathogens that circulate among them
exactly i know it's hard to believe but
the cold mechanized factories that cram
animals together before stamping their
flesh into plastic meat molds and
injecting the outcome into supermarket
freezer sections across the nation
might be doing something bad and when
you put
all of this together it does begin to
seem like we're actively trying to start
pandemics
which brings us to the obvious question
how do we stop
doing that well the most effective way
would be to close down all wildlife
markets
ban factory farming stop eating meat
altogether halt deforestation
shut down all state fairs and definitely
take away paris hilton's kinkajou but
obviously
none of those are going to happen for
one thing we know that kinkajou bites
but also draconian measures are just not
going to work here
for instance if you abolish wildlife
markets that could cause
food scarcity and would likely just lead
to an explosion in black market trade of
wild animals
the reason we know that is that's
reportedly exactly what happened when
china attempted just such a ban in 2003
in response to sars which is not to say
that we shouldn't try to reduce
harmful practices because we clearly
should many experts argue what's called
a
one health perspective where we
recognize that the health of humans
animals and our environment are all
interconnected
and take that into account when making
decisions on everything from
environmental regulations
to urban planning and there are going to
need to be lots of smaller solutions
here too
which will look different everywhere
because crucially everywhere
is different take thailand they have had
some real success in preventing
outbreaks there by providing farmers
with a phone app
to flag any problems that they see it's
similar to
my instagram without any filters that
help the volunteers in the village to
submit abnormal health even in real time
you couldn't train everyone to be a
health expert
but you can train everyone to be eye and
ears
that's very clever because with that app
farmers there
now have a way to spot a possibly sick
bird that could inform broader public
policy which
isn't just effective disease prevention
it was also interestingly
the working title of this show now that
scheme has been a success partly because
it preserves people's livelihoods and
aligns farmers interests with those of
their larger community and there will be
thousands of small ideas like that that
could end up making a
real difference and look there is no
denying all of this is going to cost
money and unfortunately
some scientists doubt our appetite for
long-term spending on this just listen
to this researcher in brazil make that
exact point
while taking samples from bats it's
extremely difficult to get funding for
our kind of research
now during the pandemic it has been a
little easier
but as soon as the virus crisis is over
our financial worries will return
i'm not very optimistic yeah that's not
great
is it because i'm not very optimistic
isn't really what you want to hear from
someone scraping germs out of a bat
that's a woman who literally knows her
so we need to spend however much is
necessary to change her
answer there and i'm not saying that
this will be cheap one estimate for the
cost of global prevention runs between
and 31 billion dollars a year but bear
in mind
even if it was double that the cost of
kovid 19 in the u.s alone is estimated
to be over 16
trillion so to put it mildly it's
worth it
and i know right now that might seem
obvious the problem is
as we come out the other side of this
pandemic there is a real danger that
we're going to start to get complacent
so for the good of future generations
and
in all likelihood us in a few years time
we really need to remember the way we
feel right now
and invest accordingly because the truth
is you never know
where the next pandemic is going to come
from hey y'all
remember me oh yuck and i'm gonna do
what the coronavirus couldn't
i'm gonna kill tom hanks well please
don't do that virus serena wilson too
they're gonna call me oliver's plague i
really don't want you to be called that
oh i think it's got a ring to it i
absolutely don't
the point is we have got to remember
this feeling it's our only hope
that's our show thank you so much for
watching we'll see you next week good
night
john when i first break out do you think
a bunch of celebrities will make a video
of themselves singing
imagine i mean probably to be honest
i've got a surprise for you
what is your surprise i can spread
through zoom
how can you spread through zoos oh it's
full of miracles now if you'll excuse me
i'm going to disney world and i'm going
to give everyone
bloody diarrhea
i hate you